- The United States' Declaration
of Independence reads,
we hold these truths to be self-evident
that all men are created equal,
that they are endowed by their creator
with certain unalienable rights.
That sounds great, but
who does it apply to?
And what are those rights?
That's what we are going to
discuss in these lessons.
We're going to think about what rights
do you have as an individual,
and what rights might
you give up to the state.
We'll talk about the
history of civil rights
and civil liberties in the United States.
Even though we have these very
powerful and very high-minded
words in the Declaration
of Independence in 1776,
not all men, and especially not all women,
had these types of rights,
as the nation was founded
in the 1780s and 1790s.
How did that evolve,
and how will that story
continue to evolve as the United States
tries to become a more perfect union?
In these lessons, we're gonna make sure
we understand the difference between, say,
a civil liberty and a civil right.
We're also going to learn a
lot about the Bill of Rights
and what liberties and
rights they protect.
And finally, we're going to
learn how people have organized
throughout American history to make change
and to ensure that as a nation,
we are as just of a nation as possible.
And so whether your concern is
what rights do I have if I get arrested
to how do I make sure that
I live in a just society,
these lessons are going
to be interesting for you.
So I'm excited about going
on this journey with you.
And if you want to learn more
and get deep practice
with immediate feedback,
I encourage you to look at these
lessons on KhanAcademy.org.